yeah I'm going home got a whole lot but
I'm a short better recognize game
[Music]
let all right speaking of the cipher I
wanted to ask you this question I had
somebody up here Machine Gun Kelly who a
lot of people compare him to you I don't
I don't know why good um he's a cool
dude though he's really nice guy I
imagine um but he just did a with The
Breakfast Club in in New York which I
know you are you know you know I've
heard about this but I haven't heard it
what he said was they asked him if he
liked yellow wolf cuz Charlemagne he he
was like oh it's yellow wolf okay but he
he called him yellow he's like oh look
it's yellow
wolf man hates me what he asked him if
he liked if he liked uh you as as an
artist and he and he you know he said
that he he hadn't listened to you and he
said that uh you take shots at him all
the time and he thought you took shots
at him in the in the verse the cyer
verse you know where he said so many
white rappers to pick from before you
pick a pepper whatever is that were you
taking shots at anybody in particular is
it just kind of people being a little
sensitive yeah he's uh he's being
sensitive he thinks I'm talking about
him the big the best thing that he can
do is if he has a problem or if he has
something he needs to say to
me just
say my
name dog like what this is hip-hop if
you got something you want to rap about
just rap about it man you know cuz like
at the end of the day man it's not
like this is the God's honest truth on
the Bible I haven't um heard any of his
songs right that's just the truth and
I'm not like I don't see you I don't see
you on the blogs like listening to [__]
just because a rapper is white I don't
feel the need to attack them right you
know part of my crew is white rappers
rits struggle like Marshall matters like
come on like you know what I'm saying I
I don't I don't that's not at all my aim
um I've worked really hard for a long
time to
um create a style and a sound that is
all my own taken from The Inspirations
that I've pulled from from beasties and
red men and you know as far as live
shows go Cypress Hill and Triple 6 Mafia
you know just trying to give a rebirth
to that
energy and
um so I I I heard there was some things
that I that I needed to watch some
comments so after the BET Awards
actually like man you need to watch this
and
um this guy was going on about
how no one else needs to be doing and
this and that and are you talking about
like uh like crowds surfing and stuff
yeah like I we we started this when no
one was headbanging we were headbanging
and
like I I really was in awe I I just I
couldn't believe he was he had the
audacity to say that not on not even on
my behalf take me out of the equation
this is hip-hop man this is music is
very broad you know like I mean little
Wayne Wayne is skateboarding right now I
had people in my crew wasn't
Skateboarding 2 years ago I like no no I
had people in my crew that are straight
hardcore that came off a Warp Tour
hardcore fans it's the hardcore music
I'm the first hip-hop tour they ever
been on
right they were offended and they don't
even do not for me for them like Mar pit
the [__] is you know like they were like
what so anyway at the end of the day man
you know it's all it's all it could all
it could all be um boiled down to um you
know just records man you know I'm
trying to make classic records and if he
wants it he can come get it I'm I'm G
say it like that I didn't mean to start
any uh beef but no I mean ain't no ain't
no beef started I'm just saying like I'm
just I'm just saying
this put it put it on whack I I mean I
have no problem I look I just left I
just left where were we what where is he
from Cleveland
Cleveland sold out show in Cleveland I
saw that I saw the line on uh the twit
pic and u um them them folks were
jumping around having a blast I had a
good time I thought he was going to come
out I heard I heard he was invited you
know and I was going to bring him to the
bus and chop it up with him you know and
see what was happening you know cuz I'm
I was put out there put everything out
there I was just curious to see what was
going on you know but he didn't he
didn't come out but his city is amazing
and thank you
Cleveland um I love you I'll be back you
know on my next tour radioactive tour
you know make sure you pick Up
Radioactive is dropping November
21st oh my [__] phone would go off in
the middle of the interview so
uh we're happy but MGK I hold no no hoes
barred homie Machine Gun Kelly if I'm
not clear Machine Gun Kelly if you want
it come get it drop your verse do
whatever you want to do if you want to
take it there we can take it there and
that goes for anybody else out there too
if you feeling froggy jump [__]
okay all right well I think that was
pretty self-explanatory man yeah and if
you don't then cool let's have a drink
you know we go out and kick it I mean I
dude I love I love hip-hop I love I love
what it is I love the competition of it
all have you ever had a beef in your you
know you've been rapping for a long time
never man I've never had anyone I've had
people attack me critically you know
like Charlamagne right or champagne
what's his name his name
Charlamagne champagne the
god um he said some really foul things
that got under my skin but he's not a
rapper you know so it's like H and plus
there why even address I mean people
were going to listen my mama hates Bob
Dylan I don't know why she hates Bob
Dylan I'm a huge Bob Dylan fan point is
people are going to like [__] and
they're not going to like [__] and
sometimes you don't know why like I'm
definitely one of those artists you
either love me or hate
me